like the first time we met was on the
ice it was for training so he because of
Glory he didn't get a he didn't get uh
connected to the film until after I did
like uh originally it was going to be
Ben Stiller and I and then Ben couldn't
do it so you know but Ben was producing
he was like don't worry John we'll get
someone else I was like I was so bummed
and then he was like oh we got Will
Ferrell it was I was like okay that's
pretty cool I guess I know you didn't
you know of course no I was like I was
just like oh my okay that's pretty sweet
because so yes but the first time we met
because he was so humbled I think
humbled by the ice right I was just like
he was I just remember he's like you
ready to do this and I was like this is
a perfect thing for him to say because I
could see kind of the excitement but
also he knew like I was I don't know
like I he was a really cool senior in
high school with the Letterman's jacket
and I was Lucas the nerdy little
freshman who was being taken under his
wing and it introduced me to all his
like cool high school buddies could you
tell Will liked you was there something
as you tell he like or was it just
business and he was like Hey great
seeing you like or did you guys hang out
or what come on dude what's not to like
what's not to like no I yeah he was I
mean I think he liked me I mean he
didn't see but he was very down to earth
not at all he didn't BS BS anything like
he was very kind and sweet and did he
make you laugh a lot oh yeah but he
wasn't trying he was just like he was a
filmmaker like he was like oh like let's
do this if you think about it and like
all right let's uh do this thing but he
was also kind of like just chill and
like would make jokes we'd laugh about
people on set or like oh what about this
guy and we try things out
I loved working working with it was it
was a dream come true yeah
um and you know I learned a ton but yeah
he was I think he liked me uh I will say
this I will say this this is cool
so you know unlike a lot of other you
know I've worked with a lot of people
and I don't keep in contact with most of
them I mean not out of choice it's just
like you know Will's on another level
and and honestly I don't have his number
I never gotta stop her we were thinking
sharing stuff so but I years later years
later this is the first time I had seen
him
like there was something we were trying
to produce and get made back in 2010 so
I saw him then or 20 2009 right so it
was years later this is a couple years
ago we I go to this um
uh screening in La for a show that he
was in and but he was a small part in it
but I was invited regardless by I think
my management so I bring my buddy and
we're going and it is my buddy who's not
in the business at all I was like this
would be fun to bring him here there's a
lot of people it's just it would be a
fun thing to watch so we're walking
around and in the after party you know
they have all this tents set up and I
finally see Will and he's in the back
back corner kind of alone
and you know admittedly looking kind of
tired and a little grayer that I
remember but it was just he was tired
and and he wasn't standing he was just
sitting the whole time and everybody
around him was like you know standing
and talking to him but it wasn't a huge
crowd I don't know like it was just he
probably just wanted it to be kind of
quiet alone
but and I was like sitting there with my
buddy I was like dude you have to go
like you did a movie with them I was
like I know I know but I never liked
bothering people I just like especially
at parties like I don't even bother them
but it is a party he wouldn't have come
if he wasn't ready to socialize a little
bit so you went over so I was like fine
I was like but I did say to my friend
like watch this watch this like see him
because the interesting thing he wasn't
standing up at all he wasn't standing at
all and I'm guessing he was just tired
and like oh people can sit down or talk
to me I was like dude watch this he's
gonna stand for me so you know I walk
over there finally I was like dude will
I you know we lock eyes and he's just
like
big eyes and she's like
and he stands up and gives me a big hug
and I was just like looking at my
friends like yeah yeah no no I was just
like yeah and it was great to have that
reunion and it was like oh I mean he'll
always have a special place in my heart
and I hope I have this same place that's
nice